foreign
[Music]
on June 3rd Lionel Messi played his last
game for Barry sanjana against Claremore
in France's Liga
now with the 38 year old Cristiano
Ronaldo playing in Saudi Arabia the
Messi Ronaldo rivalry the best in the
game's history is probably ending at top
level but who won
goals seem a crude measure but there are
good way to Value forwards Ronaldo leads
slightly but only because he scored more
penalties
Messi is narrowly ahead on non-penalty
goals after a shorter career
add-in assists laying on goals for
teammates and it's clear Messi is the
greater player whereas Ronaldo is merely
a brilliant goalscorer Messi is two in
one brilliant scorer and Brilliant
provider
both sustain their greatness for nearly
20 years which is unprecedented
they benefited from improved nutrition
training and a Crackdown on violent
fouls Messi has won more individual and
team honors than Ronaldo but we
shouldn't over interpret Messi winning
the World Cup especially because
Argentina has more than four times
Portugal's population and Ronaldo was 37
in Qatar
but note that Argentina is the only
non-european country even to reach the
podium the top three places in the last
five World Cups that's how special Messi
is he can beat the best Europeans
had Messi and Ronaldo quit around 2019
their careers would still have dwarfed
all their predecessors in almost any
other era Ronaldo would have been the
best
Lewandowski and Benzema also benefited
from unprecedented longevity scoring
into their mid-thirties
over their careers they too have now
outscored all past greats a Mappy in
Highland are rising but the best young
player ever was arguably Ronaldo
fenomeno the Brazilian
true he scored his early goals in the
Brazilian and Dutch leagues but at a
time when those leagues were relatively
strong
Ronaldo then suffered several serious
injuries which blighted his career
he still won a World Cup
without injuries could he have outshone
Messi
foreign